The fourth line here, with a call to add series,
simply specifies what type of chart we would like to make.
In this case,
we pass a dimple.plot.bar chart to the add series called on my chart.
In nuance here, that we'll get into later,
this first mysterious argument that we pass in as null.
Dimple J S, being the high level charting library that it is,
allows us to facet our data or droop it by another column.
If we wanted to say plot our data by attendance per year but
also droop it by let say the stage of the World Cup, we could pass as the first
argument to the series stage, which will first group our data by stage and
then make a bar plot of the specified axes on the chart.